hat man schon mal in einem brett bohren
so ein gewerk verbuchen
aber mein name ist herzlich willkommen
wir heute seinen neuen video hat der
sicherlich alle die debatte um ist mehr
viel mitbekommen
eventuell noch einige unter euch gibt
ihnen noch nicht ganz genau mitbekommen
haben basten wird mehr habt ihr denn
finger der abwicklung liegt waren so
aber hat auf dem kanal von shirin date
mit ihr ein video hochgeladen und hat so
werdet ihr held kassiert weil er sich
schon öfters mit einem eigenen content
als schwulenfeindlich welt dargestellt
hat und gesagt hat dass er das nicht
toleriert wenn leute homosexuellen und
daraufhin hat er halt ein bild mit
hochgeladen der 14 minuten lang war sie
nur will beleidigt hat und das bahn
befinden also wir tolerieren welt
verhalten überhaupt mit unseren total
gegen das ganze arbeit bedeutet auch ein
video hochladen wo ich denn anbieter
unter youtuber finde einfach darauf
reagiert und sagt dass man kriegt so auf
jeden fall nicht geben das ist komplett
falsch
deswegen habe man keine spielchen
überlegt also die zitate von meer und
die gärten auch da haben wir ziemlich
dumm und ich habe mir auch ähnlich dumm
aussah überlegt und luca beraten welche
aufnahme punkten und welches tatsächlich
den gleichen gewinn von mehr
[Musik]
die gedankenspiele schulen und anderen
menschen sind marionetten
diese verfügten verschmutzten ehren
losen menschen etwas kann der beide
finden ist das bild nicht nur drei
minuten der tragen können deswegen kann
ich jetzt auch dieses video aufnehmen
ohne jede einzelne paar tage merken
haben zu können tun dann müssen müssen
genau ich würde sagen das ist die erste
aussage ist mit die mit ihrem mann die
ganzen schule und randen [ __ ] silber
für den menschen in allen nennen
das war eine ersten minuten diese ganzen
schwulen schwule und kranken [ __ ]
gottlosen menschen sind auch marionetten
diese ganzen linie
richtig bestimmt traurig geworden könnte
von ihm seien die bekannten [ __ ]
weniger freuen oder event jetzt bestimmt
wieder hektische phase war ich mir nicht
weiter aufgeweicht worden war wieder die
zwischen traurig geworden
im mittelpunkt der beweis gestellt
echte männer stehen einfach überraschen
[ __ ] weil mit ihrem leben
wenn ihr sei bekannt in einem video für
mich du würdest das bestimmt machen und
trotzdem da
das ist wahrscheinlich schon klare
antwort bei der tat waren noch mal echte
männer schienen einfach drüber kopflosen
fuchteln weil sie mit ihrem leben und
das andere ist wenn ich dir sage tanken
ein video zu machen
gefragt auf die beleidigung verstecken
will ich würde sagen das erste vier
tiere loswerden
da hatten wir auch der geräte ihren los
ist und erde die hat er diesen schritt
weiter wenn ich dir klage tappt in einem
video für mich gehört ist das doch
machen
der spätere dabei irgendwie im lächeln
wieder
ja das hab ich gehört dass dort alles
abgesprochen war
wenn er mit diesen fans darin videos
gemacht hat ich kenne printen aber gar
nicht ganz offen zu und er hat mehr die
rechte gegeben ihn bleibe für die
vergabe nicht mehr verwirklichen suchte
und deren verteidiger piqué was kann
schon sagen dass man mich irgendwie
nicht widerlegen kann mach mal schwere
verläufe von recht und auf den märkten
wird das hat aber derzeit stehen dass
weisswein für mich
[Musik]
und ihr könnt ihr das gewollt hätten
ich verkaufe product placement
klassiker wenn 20 mit einem video machen
kann nämlich den sturm etwa die lage
welche von beiden ortslagen merken video
getroffen wird aber glücklich bürger
waren zwei aussagen die er wirklich
verkaufen oder sprechen und wurde klar
wie garics taten sie mit einem video
machen kann die versicherung eine von
beiden wirklich in dem video gesagt ich
würde sagen auch zwei recht verkauf
dieser produkte
dicker ich fühle mich ihren präsidenten
[Musik]
ich fühle mich geehrt fühle mich nicht
wundern wenn für mich jemand in den
nacken weil ich die ware
die medien warten schon darauf dass dem
streiten können beitrag gegen ihre
schulen und tranken gesagt habe aber ich
habe meine einfahrt fordert mich war das
wirklich verwirre sagte präsident ist
und dass man ihn schon die wahrheit
hören waren mit ihren klaren bezug zur
realität
ich würde sagen weil wir verlangen dass
ich weiter meine truppe die am kamin
überlebt die autofenster werden könnte
aber ich auch zeit wird auch ein bittet
wenn ich für mich der präsident gerade
ich will mich jetzt auf die unbedingt
die wahrheit gesagt habe
eine denkbar
leckere dann wieder besetzt wird punkte
abgebaut worden
[Musik]
ich bin einfach der kraftwerker von
einigen youtuber spruch den deshalb
feierliche alle
ich bin der einzige ex über der treppe
wahrgenommen wird beide trugen sage ich
glaube mein kopf sagt noch schreibe ich
bezweifle dass mit chris cools von drei
minuten lang und ich glaube auch weiter
auf seine wurde in den ersten drei
minuten über alle bürger auf jeden fall
schon gemerkt
nicht weiter auf der steht auch blätter
der investition denn gesagt wer hier
drin und deswegen diese gelten fabriken
youtube auch niemand so gut ankommt
becker ihr habt in eurem video sich
einmal davor zugesagt die letzte aussage
dass der dap kriegt 40.000 punkte dem
scoreboard ich blende ich jetzt mal das
wort der 1
während ungenannten ehrenpunkte oder
riese
nach zehn arten von sechs positionen mit
einem mann achte ich mache darüber ein
video weiter kommt einfach grafikerin 1
bald machen sich heute er macht es bei
der bereich werden was als erstes macht
finale von sechs positionen mit einem
angeblich frucht und ich machen oder ein
video war das kommt einfach kraft ja den
gleichen anfang gewählt beiden und für
finale bisschen glücklich zu machen also
ich würde sagen dass wir ne oder wir
machen jetzt nämlich alltag von den
beiden auflagen
wir haben jetzt die beiden aussagen das
heißt
nach den karten von factory tun mit
einem anspruch nötig macht über ein
video es kommt einfach oder macht den
raten von sechs positionen mit einem
mann so kleines woche durch nachdem die
konturen und verprügelt wird das weiter
beweisen ich entscheide ich
gewesen
und exposition mit einem mann die plane
spotter und ich mache darüber ein video
bayer kommt einfach klappen wird im
verfahren aber ich glaube wenn man würde
ja auch beim achten länder zu erweitern
und auch irgendwie hin ab und beauftrage
dann bleibt er eben doch der folge in
richtung wo die schulen kräftig twittern
kann in keiner weise geeignet wieder
einen mittelpunkt zu stellen
der nationale rassische religiöse gruppe
auf startet zum ablauf der frist oder
aufwändigen teile der bevölkerung zum
verkauf startet angeklickt dort volk
leute das was sie mit dem ihm eine dame
aus zitiert ich manchmal nicht abheben
das waren willkommen
das team vom video gefallen wenn du das
nicht irgendwie wusste dass ich glaube
da wird oft genug
doch wir haben oft genug gesagt dafür
dass überhaupt nicht gut gemacht
schon während der andere youtuber
gemacht wenn ihr dazu ein vernünftiges
video sehen wollte drückte mit video von
dem haider an der bereich zusammenfasst
dort würde ich sagen wenn ihr einen
eingebildeten könnte mehrkanal
abonnieren und hier unten findet ihr ein
anderes video eingeblendet